Adnan ishgi: لحين
Adnan ishgi: الحمد لله إشتغل توقعت إنه ما أشتغل.
Logix Inc: طيب هذا
Logix Inc: هذه زي ما تقول اللاندينغ بيج
Logix Inc: كانت مقطع فيديو كدا على اليسار فوق في الهدر
Logix Inc: في الموقع الأول قصدي يعني اللي كانوا مسوينه الشباب.
Adnan ishgi: زي كده عربي ما يحتاج عربي زي كده ولا لأ مثلا أنا أسألك سؤال.
Logix Inc: موجود.
Adnan ishgi: آه أوكي
Adnan ishgi: أسمع الخط نقدر نغير ولا صعب.
Logix Inc: لا سهل بس أنا إخترت خطين.
Adnan ishgi: لا، لا الإنكليزي الإنجليزي خرافي. تعرف دحين السعودية حطت خط رسمي ما سمعت عنه ولا لأ.
Logix Inc: الله.
Adnan ishgi: بس سعودي خلاص إذا صعب أنسى أنسى أنسى خلاص هذا مش مهم.
Logix Inc: لا لا سهل إن شاء الله
Logix Inc: بس.
Adnan ishgi: ما هو.
Logix Inc: يعني أرسل لي لو ترسل لي بيانات الخط أو أنا أبحث عنه مو مشكلة.
Adnan ishgi: هو موجود في الموقع الرسمي حق الدولة بس يعني أنا أقولك هذا ممكن أخليه بعدين هذا مش مهم.
Logix Inc: أها تمام
Logix Inc: هو ترى الموضوع ال إنجلوس اربك
Logix Inc: شوية معقد
Logix Inc: لأنه خاصة في الديزاينغ انت تتكلم عن ليفت رايت ورايت تو ليفت انت تعكس ديزاين كلو عرفت من اليمين لليسار من اليسار لليمين،
Logix Inc: فهذا الشيء تعبني شوي صراحة في الديزاين
Logix Inc: طبعا للأسف، إلى الآن، لكن أنا الآن من اليوم رح أبدأ أشتغل خلاص في الرجل ذاته إلى الآن زي ما تقول
Logix Inc: البلاس هولدرز عارف زي ما أنت شايف اللوغوس كلها فيك ما في شي رجل إلى الآن
Logix Inc: فأنا عشان كدا ما ابغى انه توريهم شي يعني لسا فاك وكدا فهمتي.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي.
Logix Inc: يعني.
Adnan ishgi: كان عندنا أول وأنت قول لي أنا أول كان عندنا أولا
Adnan ishgi: كانت مور أوف لايك إنستغرام ولا فيسبوك لما تشوف حقتهم ما في سكرولينج داون والكلام ده صفحة واحدة بسيطة
Adnan ishgi: فيها الجملة اللي إنت كتبتها مثلا هذه حلوة مرة
Adnan ishgi: هو ممكن مثلا يكون صورة أبليكيشن جوال أو شي يعني دائما أنا أحاول أشوف أنا إنسان
Adnan ishgi: سويت مشاريع أكثر من مشروع والمشاريع اللي نجحت عندي هي مشاريع اللي لها بنش مارك في في العالم. دايما يكون عندي مثلا أشوف إيش الناجح وتلاقيني أحاول أسوي تويست حقي لأنه ما حدا الآن حيروح يخترع الكفر العجلة العجلة هي اللي تمشي السيارات يخترع كفر مربع
Adnan ishgi: فهل انت شايف إنه نسوي لاندينج بيج ببساطة
Adnan ishgi: صفحات الإنستغرام الللتين الفيسبوك دائما يحطوها صفحة بسيطة والسايناب وبعدين لما يدخل يبدأ يصير الفيلم ده كله اللي تشوفه ولا أوجه.
Logix Inc: والله ممكن ممكن لكن
Logix Inc: يعني هو على حسب المنصة
Logix Inc: اعرف على حسب يعني بلات فوربس هذه يعني
Logix Inc: زي ما تقول ما رح يقدروا شي يحطوا شيء اصلا في لاندينج لكن إحنا عندنا نقدر نعرض
Logix Inc: الإحصائيات كورسيس نفسها نقدر نعرضها زي مثلا في السكشن هذا فيتشرد كورسيس
Logix Inc: على اساس يكون في يعني
Logix Inc: لما يوزر يخش على لاندينغ بيجي يكون في انتريست من البداية
Logix Inc: يسوي نفيجاتي لصفحة ثانية عشان يشوف إيش إيش الموضوع عارف فاهم فكرة
Logix Inc: آه مثلا البرايس نقدر نحط الاسعار تحت هنا
Logix Inc: نقدر نحط
Logix Inc: تيستمونيالز
Logix Inc: بيقولوا عن المنصه الزوار والمستخدمين نفسهم هذه كلها جدا مهمة يعني هذه يعتبر تصميم
Logix Inc: المدن وبسايت كل المدن
Logix Inc: هنا آخر شيء يعني هذه طريقه جذب للزائر
Logix Inc: ها يعني شفت اللي عندنا يلا.
Adnan ishgi: علي.
Logix Inc: يلا غيت ستارتيد أو هنا كولتاشن يعني.
Adnan ishgi: خلاص ما خلص ذي فور مي ثيس فاين ذات غود آي آي اللوغز هذه تريستيد هذه ممكن نبدأ نعطيك بعض الأشياء يعني أنا ممكن ممكن أحط مثلا أكاديمي سمايا أحط الناس أحط الشركات حقتي والشركات اللي عندي شراكات فيها.
Logix Inc: ممتاز.
Adnan ishgi: البسيطة هذه.
Adnan ishgi: اقدر اضيفها لي.
Logix Inc: ممتاز. أنا عندي أكاديمي بس أبغى يعني الآن لأنه
Logix Inc: أنا أنا هنا خاصة أشتغل بصيغة جي يعني شفت.
Adnan ishgi: أنا شرحتلك الكلام ده كان معانا شريك
Adnan ishgi: مو شريكة معانا 1 هو كان مدير الحين ما هو مدير مدير في سمايا رجال كبير وأستاذنا هو اللي كان معيد علينا مدرس علينا دكتور علينا
Adnan ishgi: وهو جايب بنته سوت الشعار مع إنه يعني والله تعبت عشان أحاول أقوله
Adnan ishgi: سيبني أجيب أنا أرتب موضوع الشعر
Adnan ishgi: فوق اللي طلبها ومين طلبها مني وقالي بنتي والكلام ده وصراحة يعني دوب ومشي لو أنا جيت غيرت أي حاجة الآن في شعاره حي حيشوفها. إنه إنت ما صدقت أنا أمشي يعني كان معاه تشتغل معانا فهي هذه مثلا أشياء كلها للأسف يعني هو الشعار حيتغير حيتغير حيتغير يعني ما يبي مثلا السنة الجاية اللي بعدها ما يبي تنام برضه العلاقات حقتنا دي مهمة مع الناس هدول صراحة يعني.
Logix Inc: مو قصدي على زي مثلا سماي الباقين اللي حترسلهم عارف.
Adnan ishgi: لا، لا، أنا حخلي، الشباب
Adnan ishgi: صحيح؟
Adnan ishgi: أيوه
Adnan ishgi: نحتاجه حنرسله شوف يعني سجلت الأشياء دي أي حاجة تحتاج تحتاج وأنا أسوي العكس هذا كوميونيكيشن والله يا أحمد يطمني انت ما تستوعب قديش
Adnan ishgi: لما تطلب أعرف إنه في شي بيصير لما ما تطلب أخاف يكون ما في شغل كدا يجيني انطباع فالعكس يقولي والله تايم.
Logix Inc: تمام
Logix Inc: طبعا هذه زي ما قلنا ال لاندنغ بيج
Logix Inc: بعد ذلك في
Logix Inc: السكشنز
Logix Inc: يعني الرئيسية حطيتها يعني تو مينيوز يعني باختصار زي ما تقول عارف
Logix Inc: فيها كورسيس حق نفس الشخص اليوزر المسجل
Logix Inc: بوك ماركس يعني لو في كورس عجبه مثلا يبغى يسجل فيه لاحقا يحطوا هذا بوك مارك
Logix Inc: إنستروكتورز المفروض كوتشز أو
Logix Inc: اللي قلت عليها. انت.
Adnan ishgi: يس طيب شوف شيء ثاني أم
Adnan ishgi: يعني على قد علمي هذا طبعا كمان أستشيرك فيها أنا يهمني حاجة اسمها. أنا أطبقها. طول الوقت. حياتي سوينا كورس معين يوزر إكسبيرس مؤتمر يوزر إكسبيرز أنا يهمني اللي يدخل من يوم ما دخل الخرج يقول تنظيم مو طبيعي وعندنا جبارة ترى عالموضوع ده سو
Adnan ishgi: نحنا لما جينا للتطبيق،
Adnan ishgi: حطينا 3 أشياء ما في غير ما في غيرها صراحة كليت يفنت
Adnan ishgi: بعدين كوتشينج و كوميونيتي هم 3 هم بس هي بالضبط فور فومشن يقدروا يحطوا بوستاتهم زي الإنستغرام كوميونيتي يسووا زي كده زي الواتساب آه عندهم الكوتشينج اللي هو عبارة عن ملخصات أي حاجة مسجلة أو
Adnan ishgi: بعدين عندنا الشي اللي هي لايف ويث أون لاين ولا فيزيكال سو نحن عندنا 4 ميجر فونكشنز سو أم
Adnan ishgi: الفكرة الفكرة من الأربع دول تسهيلا على الناس
Adnan ishgi: هم في أي
Adnan ishgi: أنا بس أخاف من المصطلحات. أنا ما عندي مشكلة ما هي حلوة آه لما نغيرها ما عندي مشكلة
Adnan ishgi: بس أنا يهمني إنه إيش ما إتفقنا؟ يكون أبليكيشن الويب سايت نفس كونسبت
Adnan ishgi: أخاف بس إنو
Adnan ishgi: المصطلحات خش لان تخش على تيج على تويتر تويتر تخش على كوتشي صدقني حيبطوا يتلخبطوا
Adnan ishgi: آه ما تنسى كثير من الناس الإنكليزي يا دوبك صراحة يعرف كلمة من الأربع كلمات هذه كلها داخلة ببعض فأنا نفسي يكون إحنا اتفقنا على كده في الأول إنه هذه هي الفور فونكشنز
Adnan ishgi: يمكن الويب سايت مقتنع جدا صراحة يمكن الفونكشن حق البوستات ما تكون شغالة يعني لو قلتلي ما في داعي بوست تشتغل في الويب سايت ممكن أقتنع يعني زي الإنستغرام مو مشكلة بس تقولي كوميونيتي وأسوي كورسات وأسوي أنزل كورديت يمكن في ناس تهمها اللابتوب لأنه شوف المحاضرات بشكل أوضح الشاشة كبيرة إلى آخره التعليم فيه أفضل والريميك فيه أفضل من الجوال
Adnan ishgi: ف
Adnan ishgi: فأنا يهمني 4 فونك تكون واضحة تتكرر أل ذي تايم على الإذن يعني الحين مثلا عندنا مكاني
Adnan ishgi: صار اسمه هوا
Adnan ishgi: ده حين كل الناس تتكلم هوس براند عندنا فأنا مثلا لما يبدأ يصير نفس الشي مثلا بعدين يقولك أو إكسبورت كوتشينج أوفنت
Adnan ishgi: حتبدأ يصير هذا برضه خلاص الناس عارفة يروح يقولك روح نسوي إيش هالكلمة ما عندي مشكلة بس نتفق عليها وتطبق خلاص رسمي لخبط الناس فشوف هذا الشي يعني يمكن إنت تسجله على أساس إنك ترجعله إحنا عندنا 4 رئيسية مرة واضحة.
Adnan ishgi: إنت عندك مقترحات عندك إضافات نسمع ما عنا مشكلة بس أهم شي أنو تكون متفقين عشان بس أخاف تسوي ستروكتور كامل يكون مو ماشي مع حاطينه.
Logix Inc: لا، لا، أنا بديت بناء على الأربع. أنا بديت الجديد البروجكت الجديد بناء على نفس كونسبت حق بروجكت القديم اللي كانوا شغالين عليه الشباب عارف يعني حتى هنا في نفس الكود
Logix Inc: قسمت
Logix Inc: سويتها دومينز
Logix Inc: يعني
Logix Inc: خلاص ال يفنت
Logix Inc: لها ذات خاصة في لها
Logix Inc: يعني مثل ما تقول الأي بي اي خاص فيها لها كوميونيتي والكورسيس
Logix Inc: الرابع
Logix Inc: كورس كوميونيتي يفنتس و ديسكاشنز.
Adnan ishgi: طيب يصير
Adnan ishgi: هو كوميونيتي صح؟ وكوتشينك اللي هو ريكوردت فيديوز أو يعني 1 حط ملخص
Adnan ishgi: ببيع ملخص بيوزعه.
Logix Inc: اللي هو الكورسات.
Adnan ishgi: أيوة أي شي خلاص ممكن يسميها كورسات عادي يعني ممكن يسميها
Adnan ishgi: بس دقيقة عشان بس عشان أوريك إحنا دخلنا كل هذه النقاشات في السنتين اللي راحت كلن عملنا النقاشات دي وخلصنا منها
Adnan ishgi: يعني أنا بسوي كورس يعني مثلا عندي كورس أنا حسوي أسبوع مثلا بعد شهر
Adnan ishgi: طيب كنت حتعمل كورس فهل كورس
Adnan ishgi: هي نفسها ال كوردت
Adnan ishgi: كيف حنجسمها؟
Adnan ishgi: هل هل.
Logix Inc: لا انا فكرتي هنا. انه الكورس كورس اللي هو أون لاين كورس هو يفنت يفنت
Logix Inc: يعني يختلف عن هاوس دي أكاديمي عرفت.
Adnan ishgi: طيب يعني الآن معلش الحين كورسيس هذه أو كورسيس هذه إيش مسجلة ولا لايف حتكون ولا حتكون في المستقبل إيش وضعها هذه.
Logix Inc: هذه دقيقة أوريك بالضبط.
Logix Inc: الوقت لا
Logix Inc: ديت كورس
Logix Inc: طبعا لسا الوضع ترى ملخبط شوية خاصة في اللي هو
Logix Inc: مكان ما تسوي الكورسات زي زي هنا ترى أنا مقسمها نفس تقريبا أو حتى الآن. صاروا 4 سيبريت أبس
Logix Inc: كل 1 له خصائصه الخاصة فيه.
Logix Inc: فهنا كلية كورس كلية نيو كورس.
Adnan ishgi: حلو.
Logix Inc: نضيف التايتل تيست كورس مثلا
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: إنستروكتور
Logix Inc: أنا
Logix Inc: ديسكريبشن
Logix Inc: دست
Logix Inc: لازم
Logix Inc: شفتي كارد الترس
Logix Inc: آه تضيف إمج
Logix Inc: آه حتى هنا سهلتها شوي خليتها على طريق ستيبس خلاص الآن نكس استب
Logix Inc: في حاجات هنا.
Adnan ishgi: جبار.
Logix Inc: الراتنغ المفروض تكون يوزرز هم اللي يحطوها مو
Logix Inc: أيوة أيوة أيوة صح؟
Logix Inc: فهذه رح تنشال
Logix Inc: في هذي برضو هيرجت بروفايدر هذه أنا ليش بسوي في في البروفايدر اللي هي أنا ما أبغى
Logix Inc: انه نخش نفس غلطة اللي صارت في
Logix Inc: إنها تكون ليميتد يعني شفت لما جاء جاء موضوع الكروز
Logix Inc: هنا اضطريت أغير أشياء ومدري شو سويت وفعلت لا انا ابغاه ديناميك عارف أبغى الموضوع ديناميك
Logix Inc: مهما كان الكورس
Logix Inc: طريقة إنشاء الكورس تكون موحدة
Logix Inc: فهمت كيف.
Adnan ishgi: جميل.
Logix Inc: فهنا هذا برضه أنا لسه شغال في الموضوع. هذا
Logix Inc: كاتشغوري مثلا
Logix Inc: وات يفر.
Adnan ishgi: جميل.
Logix Inc: إدخال وليست ل 6 صح
Logix Inc: كان ببوس إيت كانبي.
Adnan ishgi: طب.
Logix Inc: معليش
Logix Inc: ليست أور مانوالي.
Adnan ishgi: لا لو دخل مال هو سؤال لو هلك تجري عبارة عن هاشتاغات.
Logix Inc: لا في دحين حنيجي لنكسب في.
Adnan ishgi: يعني يمكن هذه ممكن إحنا عملنا أول كاتجري أظن فيها 50 شيء رئيسي يعني ما حبينا نزود.
Logix Inc: فائدتها في في.
Adnan ishgi: أيوة أيوة. صحيح؟ إذا في هاشتاغ ممكن هذه إضافة حلوة.
Logix Inc: برضه حتى الهاشتاغ راح يكون برضه يعني لما تبحث بإسم هاشتاغ معين يطلعلك جميع الكورسات اللي بنفس اسم الهاشتاغ اللي انت بحثت عنه أو حتى بالتايت حق الكورس أو بالكاتيغوري حق كورس زي كده.
Adnan ishgi: والهاشتاغ سيرشابل في في الموقع.
Logix Inc: أيوة أيوة أيوة.
Adnan ishgi: طيب.
Logix Inc: هنا البرايس
Logix Inc: مفروض ريال
Logix Inc: هذه برضه
Logix Inc: هذه موضوع اللي انت قلتلها عليه
Logix Inc: عندما نسجل ولا اعرف.
Adnan ishgi: رح تكون من هنا.
Logix Inc: مثلا إجا يسجل
Logix Inc: ولي.
Adnan ishgi: أها
Adnan ishgi: فارس
Adnan ishgi: هذا معلش دحين أنا أنا يوزر حلو.
Logix Inc: أم.
Adnan ishgi: أنا إيش أختار هنا ستاندرد ولا إيش أختار هنا مثلا.
Logix Inc: لا هنا المفروض أصلا ما ما يطلعلك إلا إذا أنت مسوي طبعا أنا لسه ما خشيت موضوع سوبسكريبشن الى الان
Logix Inc: فرنش.
Adnan ishgi: ال بلانت عارف
Adnan ishgi: أيوة أيوة.
Logix Inc: نموذج.
Logix Inc: فهنا المفروض انه
Logix Inc: لما يكون دافع مثلا حق
Logix Inc: بورت برايسنغ
Logix Inc: كوربري سوبسكريبشن
Logix Inc: المفروض هنا خلاص أوتوماتيكلي يكون.
Adnan ishgi: آه خلاص.
Logix Inc: كوربرت.
Adnan ishgi: خلاص خلاص واضح واضح.
Logix Inc: هنا كورس بوب
Logix Inc: على اساس مثلا أخليه درافت الان وبعدها يقوم بتعديلات امام.
Adnan ishgi: شفت هذه الأشياء ما تجي ببالنا إحنا شوفت.
Logix Inc: مهو. انا عشان كده أقولك هل تقارن الشغل هذا بشغل الشباب؟
Logix Inc: لا مستحيل لا والله مستحيل
Logix Inc: فشوف هنا الزبدة زي ما تقول.
Adnan ishgi: هذا كله التسجيل هذا.
Logix Inc: أي إضافة
Logix Inc: الباسي كان فوق أول درس هنا.
Adnan ishgi: حلو.
Logix Inc: فيرست
Logix Inc: الأمور. هذه مدة الخمسة و70 دقيقة
Logix Inc: خلاص هنا تسوي أدليسن يضيفلك طبعا يبدأ يحسب كل ما تضيف لسن يضيف على هذه
Logix Inc: يعني نضيف مثلا ثاني
Logix Inc: تس تو.
Adnan ishgi: والفيديو كونت والمتيريز اللي فوق.
Logix Inc: 88
Logix Inc: صارت إعلان مدة هذه برضه مفيدة ليش لأنه في الكارت اللي حتعرض في لاندينج بيج حيعرض لكن هنا، كورس هذا حياخد منك ساعتين
Logix Inc: 43 دقيقة لكي تكمل وعارف زي كده.
Adnan ishgi: لما تضغط ليسن ليسن معلش هذه.
Logix Inc: هنا الفيديو كونت ترفع الفيديو حق الليسن هذا
Logix Inc: أو حتى تقدر الآن في مثلا رابط تحط رابط ولا
Logix Inc: هو فيو إسمه
Logix Inc: لا فينمو حق فلوس فيمو زي اليوتيوب أو يوتيوب أو.
Adnan ishgi: طيب لما تحط يوتيوب هذه طلعه على برا ولا ولا
Adnan ishgi: لا؟ لا.
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: شسموها
Logix Inc: زي ما قلت.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي خلاص حلو طيب حلو.
Logix Inc: وهنا ال ماتيريال
Logix Inc: حتى يكون على الموضوع. هذا ماتيريالس.
Adnan ishgi: حلو.
Logix Inc: فرنش
Logix Inc: فخلاص هنا تسوي الاضافات. هذه
Logix Inc: سيريال.
Adnan ishgi: روعة يا أحمد.
Logix Inc: أبديت لسن
Logix Inc: هنا لسه شغال عليه اللي هو مثلا خلاص الان خلصت موضوع الليسنس نزل
Logix Inc: بالكويزيز أند أسيستمنت
Logix Inc: هنا. في مشكلة. انا الان الان شغال هنا.
Logix Inc: فشوف لما أحط حيصير
Logix Inc: بريك لل أبليكيشن لأنه في مشكلة في الكود هنا بس ما أبغى أسوي عشان لو سويتها نعيد من أول جديد
Logix Inc: المهم هنا موضوع انه شوف الاسم هذا
Logix Inc: فيرستن
Logix Inc: حيكون لو كويز
Logix Inc: اللي هو سواء تكلمنا عنها قبل كده طبعا.
Adnan ishgi: حلو.
Logix Inc: أو تشيك مارك أو
Logix Inc: خلاص هذا كويز كويز كويز مثلا فيك كويز
Logix Inc: دقيقة مو هنا يصير بريك أيوة كويس هنا يصير بريك.
Adnan ishgi: دقيقة بس دقيقة أحمد
Adnan ishgi: تمام أمورك تمام
Adnan ishgi: قشطة
Adnan ishgi: في
Adnan ishgi: لا لا احنا لسه في النص لا لا حتى قبل النص. قوي كده
Adnan ishgi: طيب
Adnan ishgi: ماشي أيوا خليك ليس بعدين نشرحلك يصير طيب طيب ماشي
Adnan ishgi: والله عايز يمكن يدخل هو يقول بس كده يسمع يعني.
Logix Inc: تمام تمام
Logix Inc: فا
Logix Inc: اللي يصير في بريك أبليكيشن.
Adnan ishgi: لا، لا.
Logix Inc: كويز.
Adnan ishgi: حلو.
Logix Inc: كويز تاتلز تيست كويز مثلا
Logix Inc: كزنس كريبشن سكور
Logix Inc: تكدر تضيف سكور.
Adnan ishgi: أخي روعة روعة روعة روعة بس لا تحطلك.
Logix Inc: لا، لا كانسير
Logix Inc: في تايم ليميت برضو.
Adnan ishgi: والله.
Logix Inc: مثلا
Logix Inc: والله خلاص كويس شايف.
Adnan ishgi: عشان ما حتى بس لازم تحط
Adnan ishgi: لا عشان.
Logix Inc: كان.
Adnan ishgi: أسئلة حقيقية.
Logix Inc: ونفس الشيء في
Logix Inc: اسمي كويس تاتل وسكور.
Adnan ishgi: والله.
Logix Inc: بعدين
Logix Inc: خلاص كده خلاص خلصنا آخر
Logix Inc: يعطيك الثمري حق
Logix Inc: هذه كل البيانات اللي دخلنا عشاق.
Adnan ishgi: ولما تسوي مفروض دراف برضه عشان هيك تختار درافت صح؟
Logix Inc: يس
Logix Inc: فعلا.
Adnan ishgi: والله شي جبار والله.
Logix Inc: شوف حتى هذه هذه
Logix Inc: ما حطيتها. أنا لسا حوريك الآن. يفنت
Logix Inc: أوكي
Logix Inc: إمم.
Adnan ishgi: سو. هذه الكورسيس هي الكوتشينج خاص نسميها كورسيس هذا اللي تقصده صح؟
Logix Inc: في
Logix Inc: دقيقة معلش.
Adnan ishgi: مشكلة اليفنت برضها كورسيس
Adnan ishgi: المحل
Adnan ishgi: يتلخبطوا الناس.
Logix Inc: الصقع مهم
Logix Inc: بارتر
Logix Inc: بنت.
Logix Inc: أوكي
Logix Inc: هذه نفس فكرة هاسكاديمي
Logix Inc: وورك شوب سليكترز.
Adnan ishgi: بس أسمع هذه برضه كورسيس أنا كيف أميز بين شي ريكوردتيريوس
Adnan ishgi: زحمة زهد سامعني ترى وراني شي جبار لل كورسيس
Adnan ishgi: وكيف أميز بين هنا ترى هذه تناقشنا فيها كثير.
Ahmad Zahid: السلام. عليكم سامحونا على التأخير في الدخول وبرضه انا ما زلت في المستشفى بس قلت إنه برضه شوف إيش اللي بيصير. حتى لو شوية أجلس معاكم
Ahmad Zahid: عليكم السلام ورحمة الله سلامات والله ما تشوف شر
Ahmad Zahid: الله يسلمك حبيبي والله تسلم تسلم
Ahmad Zahid: تفضلوا تدخلوا انا طبعا ما أبغى أقاطعكم لأنه أكيد سيكون عندي اسئلة اكيد تكلمتوا كثير من قبل.
Adnan ishgi: ونرجع مرة ثانية.
Logix Inc: نادر ما عندك مشكلة
Logix Inc: طيب انا فاهم النقطة اللي انت بتقول عليها دكتور
Logix Inc: هادي نخليها
Logix Inc: إذا شفنا ذي كونت فلكت
Logix Inc: رح نعيد التسمية إن شاء الله.
Adnan ishgi: آه أنا عشانك عشان تقول حياخد وقت أعدل بس قلت أبينلك إن هي فور فونكشنز رئيسية اتفقنا؟ عليها أكيد في مرة كثير فبالأخير قسمناهم ل 4 أشياء الهوم البوستات كوميونيتي يعني هذا اللي صار.
Logix Inc: لكن أنا اللي أقصده إنه خلاص هذه تسمى هذه يفنت مكانها في جدة مثلا في أكاديمية. هذه يفنت
Logix Inc: أوكي إنت حتحضر كورس بس إنها يفنت ما هي
Logix Inc: ما أدري خلينا نشوف إن شاء الله على قدام.
Adnan ishgi: طيب لا لا ترى فكرتك ممتازة ممكن يقسمها كورس زيبا في راسي
Adnan ishgi: طيب وهادي اللفنت صح؟
Logix Inc: إيه طبعا
Logix Inc: يفنت أسهل نفس نفس ال نفس نفس بالضبط
Logix Inc: سكريبشن إيماج
Logix Inc: لوكاشن كباستي رايس كاتيغوري ستاتس.
Adnan ishgi: طيب شوف
Adnan ishgi: عندنا مشكلة إحنا في.
Logix Inc: إيش.
Adnan ishgi: بعض الأحيان في في بيت
Adnan ishgi: تكون يوم 1 في بحر 3 أيام في بحر يكون مثلا في ذاك الأسبوع اليوم الأول والرابع بس اللي فيه.
Logix Inc: فا.
Adnan ishgi: هل في حلوى لأخاف نلتزم بس بأول بداية الكورس كورس 3 أيام 4 أيام مو يوم 1.
Adnan ishgi: هل هذا حل بسيط ولا حل صعب هذا.
Logix Inc: والله ها ويل وورد ثيس شو.
Ahmad Zahid: هذا تكلمنا فيها احمد عن الموضوع. انه في بنتات تكون احد 2 ربوع
Ahmad Zahid: ولا أحد تلوت خميس سامحني.
Logix Inc: وهكذا.
Ahmad Zahid: وقلنا إنه مثلا يعني أنا ماني شايف هنا مثلا لوكاشن برايس الساعة. هل الساعة من كم لكم.
Logix Inc: أيوة.
Ahmad Zahid: من متى لمتى ساعة؟ أنا شايف هنا.
Logix Inc: هذا الآن شغال هنا يعني هذا مو فاينل.
Ahmad Zahid: أوكي
Ahmad Zahid: آه.
Logix Inc: أنا بعطيكم كفكرة كيف حتكون ال يفنت كيف تكون كورس.
Ahmad Zahid: أوكي تمام
Ahmad Zahid: وفي موضوع آخر على موضوع تكون معاك ولا مع نون ولا كيف حنعملها اللي هي من صاحب اللفنت
Ahmad Zahid: إنه المفروض الفلوس ترجع للناس اللي ألريدي دفعوا
Ahmad Zahid: و آه
Ahmad Zahid: يعني هذه نتفاهم معاها مع نون ولا معاك في ال سيستم تنحط بحيث إنه كيف
Ahmad Zahid: اذا الطالب كيف ترجع له المال اذا مثلا قبلها بثمانيه واربعين ساعه اذا قبلها باربعه و20 ساعه ترجع له النصف مثل هكذا.
Logix Inc: غالبا
Logix Inc: ريفنت ريفيند سيستم يعني.
Ahmad Zahid: بس هذه يعني معاك تكون ولا نتفاهم مع نون معاه ولا مع الإثنين يعني كده مع بعض.
Logix Inc: هو شيء زي كده يعني اللي هو
Logix Inc: انت تكدر تسوي عن طريق
Logix Inc: منصة نون نفسها تدخل على الحساب
Logix Inc: المؤسسة وكدا الفنون
Logix Inc: وترى تدور على العملية الشرعية نفسها
Logix Inc: سوي ريفاند مبلغ جزئي ولا كامل المبلغ ولا
Logix Inc: وخلاص يصير يا فندم
Logix Inc: أنا أكاديمي
Logix Inc: رابط مع ال اب اي حق نون لكن كان في مشاكل
Logix Inc: آه يعني
Logix Inc: مشكله فتسبب مشاكل ثانيه والامور هذه
Logix Inc: لكن يعني ممكن تتحسن عرفت تتحسن أكثر وأكثر.
Ahmad Zahid: أوكي تمام.
Logix Inc: لكن هي الفكرة كلها. إنه تربط مع حق نون يعني كأنك انت تسوي ديفنت من نون بس في الموقع حقك فهمت كيف
Logix Inc: هو هذا اللي كنت أبغاه
Logix Inc: رعاية.
Ahmad Zahid: أوكي هو
Ahmad Zahid: دكس.
Logix Inc: تمام
Logix Inc: طيب خلاص فينا نرجع للاستب.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي.
Ahmad Zahid: سامحني. هل حيبدينا نحط صور للإفنت.
Logix Inc: أيوه
Logix Inc: من هنا.
Ahmad Zahid: أوكي
Ahmad Zahid: صح؟ أنا على اليمين سامحني أنا كنت مسوي زوم.
Logix Inc: ك.
Ahmad Zahid: من الخارج.
Logix Inc: أيوة.
Ahmad Zahid: تمام.
Logix Inc: يعني هذا.
Logix Inc: الكورس
Logix Inc: لها أكثر شوف هذا
Logix Inc: هذا أحسن شكل صراحة عجبني في
Logix Inc: كورس كارد عارف اللي هو تعرض
Logix Inc: الكورسات بالطريق هذه الصور أو حتى تقدر تضغط
Logix Inc: كلها
Logix Inc: آه حلو.
Ahmad Zahid: موضوع الكورسات لأن شكلكم خلصتوها بس السؤال هو انا ممكن اكيد في انتيركشن فيديو ألريدي.
Adnan ishgi: لي.
Ahmad Zahid: أوكي
Ahmad Zahid: فموا بعدين إن شاء الله هذه ريبورت
Ahmad Zahid: حأضطر. إني أشوف وبعدين نرجع إذا كان في أسئلة حسألها إن شاء الله في الغروب.
Logix Inc: تمام
Logix Inc: أوكي.
Ahmad Zahid: طيب عشان لما أجي أشوف الإيفنتات أنا أتوقع موضوع، ولا
Ahmad Zahid: صحيح؟
Logix Inc: أيوة أيوة.
Ahmad Zahid: طب موضوع كيف موجود؟ هل موجود كاليندر يبين ليفنتات
Ahmad Zahid: او
Ahmad Zahid: هذا تكلمنا عليه اول اذا انا سويت مثلا حقي انه في هاي لايت لون بس حتى مو لازم يبين ليش هو ليفنت بس لو لون في التاريخ ده.
Logix Inc: انو عندي شي
Logix Inc: بلاند.
Ahmad Zahid: أوكي تمام.
Logix Inc: إمم
Logix Inc: اها اوكي هنا الطقس.
Adnan ishgi: حلو
Adnan ishgi: هناك مال شفته طيب كويس.
Logix Inc: هنا
Logix Inc: هادي إيديتيفنت
Logix Inc: هنا مثلا تعدل على يفنت موجود. ألريدي
Logix Inc: حلو ال كاتيغوري وورك شاب والشاذة زي كده تحب إحنا برضه نراجع معاكساويها.
Adnan ishgi: خلصتها. قفلتها إنت.
Logix Inc: صحيح
Logix Inc: يعني حطوا شكل عمومي كما تقول عارف.
Adnan ishgi: حلو حلو خلاص كفاية.
Logix Inc: حتى مكان فيه.
Adnan ishgi: حلو في في إحنا ممكن نحط صراحة في أشياء اللي هي حقة الطب ومع الطب.
Logix Inc: ممكن يكون في كاتيجيري وساب كاتغوري يعني مثلا
Logix Inc: الطب او الهندسه او الامور هذه
Logix Inc: كاتب
Logix Inc: الهندسة هندسة مدنية يعني الأمور.
Adnan ishgi: نقدر معلش نعطيك نشتغل إحنا على الكاتيغوريوس هذه نرسلك ياه.
Ahmad Zahid: أتوقع
Ahmad Zahid: كان عندنا وحدة الزفاكر.
Adnan ishgi: بس إحنا عندنا وحدة يا احمد.
Ahmad Zahid: جنرال.
Adnan ishgi: ايوه.
Ahmad Zahid: ما هي عندنا إحنا.
Adnan ishgi: لا ما عندنا مانكات عندنا مثلا هندسة كهربائية هندسة ميكانيكية كلها عبارة عن فلو كان إنجينيرينغ وتحتها سبكة أحسن 1,000,000 مرة.
Ahmad Zahid: أيوه صح؟ صح؟
Adnan ishgi: كثير.
Logix Inc: حريص
Logix Inc: دكتورة مع
Logix Inc: مع الوقت تطور لأنه
Logix Inc: أيوا أنا مع الوقت
Logix Inc: يجيك. 1 يبغى مثلا يفك نيو يفنت مثلا في شيء ما هو موجود
Logix Inc: فمثلا نحط اد نيو مثلا عارف.
Adnan ishgi: صحيح؟ بس أنا أنا يهمني إنه نسويها من دحين عشان أنا أقدر أوري الناس إنه ما هو دينتال بس مثلا أو شيء أقولهم هذه يعني هذه تساعدني أنا في أشياء معينة
Adnan ishgi: يخليني أقدر أي أقولهم ترى على فكرة مالهم علاقة بالأسنان مالهم علاقة فدائما كل ما أقولهم يقولولي ليش بس أسنان أقولهم ما هي بس أسنان هذا كل شي.
Logix Inc: أم.
Adnan ishgi: فبرضه حلو شوف في هندسة في كده في آي تي. في في أنا متأكد دي حتيجي مع الوقت أكثر بس المينجا يمكن نغطيها كلها ترى والله يعني ما أتوقع إنه ما نغطيها كلها
Adnan ishgi: نشوف التخصصات اللي في الجامعات الرئيسية ويعني أكيد الشيء الرئيسي أكيد عبارة عن جامعة ولا كوليج فأنا حشوف إيش التخصصات الموجودة الرئيسية هذه هندسة إدارة وكذا ونحطه بعدين تجي مع الوقت هذه.
Logix Inc: مظبوط.
Adnan ishgi: طيب.
Logix Inc: ،
Logix Inc: هنا برضو نفس موضوع شغل.
Adnan ishgi: آيو ويكينج ليست ها
Adnan ishgi: والله هذه فنانة
Adnan ishgi: والله هذه شي مرة حلوة ترى يعني هذه أشياء ما جت في بالي أنا
Adnan ishgi: طول حياتي
Adnan ishgi: والله هذي جبارة.
Ahmad Zahid: حلوة ما شاء الله هذه الفكرة حلوة يدخل أوتوماتيكيا. هذا مرة جيد والله.
Adnan ishgi: إنت عارف يا أحمد إني أنا عندي نفس الحركة مانول في الأكاديمية للناس
Adnan ishgi: ودي
Adnan ishgi: نسجلهم بالغوغل فورم.
Ahmad Zahid: حلو والله ما شاء الله مرة جيدة.
Logix Inc: وهنا في الريفنت بوليسي برضه اللي هي.
Adnan ishgi: آه على فكرة.
Logix Inc: حسب الكورس يكون في لأنه اللي يحطه ديفانت بوليسي يكون مثلا اللي سوى ما هو.
Adnan ishgi: آه.
Logix Inc: كل 1 تكون مختلفة.
Adnan ishgi: طيب ممتاز أقولك على شيء لازم نحنا نضيف خانة يمكن ما هي صعبة ترى
Adnan ishgi: اللي هو عارف اللي هو أي أحد بيسوي كليت يفنت ولا يحط كورسيس
Adnan ishgi: لازم يوافق على شيء الشيء ده يشفي إنه نحنا كشركة ما إحنا مسؤولين عن المحتوى آه أشياء اللي فيها راسميد الأشياء اللي فيها إحنا ما إحنا مسؤولين إنه هو يتحمل مسؤولية كل المحتوى اللي يحطو
Adnan ishgi: آه إنه الفيز حقته قديش حتكون زي أغريمنت. إنه هذه الأشياء هي اللي حتصير متى حينودعلو الحساب إنه حينودعله حساب مثلا خمستاشر في الشهر من كل شهر إذا كان آه الخمستعشر في الشهر ده أكثر من أسبوع يعني مثلا جاء في اليوم العشرة سوا كورس
Adnan ishgi: آه أو خلص الكورس بتاريخ يوم 10 يصير هو يوم خمستاش حيستلم فلوسه مثل والله.
Logix Inc: تنحط في.
Adnan ishgi: أنا عندي الكلام هذه اللي أصلا أديتها عندي دحين زبونين حيشتغلوا في حين عملت العقود وأرسلنالهم مية كورسات عن طريقنا مانويل طيب وحيستخدموا الموقع اللي إنت عملته المؤقت بس هذه الأشياء أبغاها إن بدت أنا ما أبغى إنه هذه الأشياء تكون.
Logix Inc: أرسلولي كورس 1 بس على أساس.
Adnan ishgi: عندي عندي حرسلك هذه جاهزة. خلاص أرسلك الأشياء
Adnan ishgi: هناك أسجلها يصير كتغريس وهذا.
Logix Inc: يعني هنا موجودة في صفحة تيرمز، لكن لم أشتغل عليها نت فاونت
Logix Inc: إيه.
Adnan ishgi: أيوا عملها بالعربي. وبالإنكليزي صراحة للإكسبيرت يعني سويتها ما أخذتها من الأكاديمية سويتها لإنو حطيت
Adnan ishgi: في هالأشياء حقة الإكسبورت.
Logix Inc: إمم.
Adnan ishgi: فعملت تقريبا 8 ولا 9 بنود مهمة يعني يكونوا عارفينها يسووا عليها تشيك.
Logix Inc: تمام نرجع لنقطة نكست
Logix Inc: هنا. طبعا هذا
Logix Inc: حلو حلو
Logix Inc: هذا.
Adnan ishgi: ايوه.
Logix Inc: هذه الايديفنت احسن من كريتيفنت ستكون نفس الطريقه ايضا عارف انا وريتكم دوبل كريتيفنت فيري بيسر.
Adnan ishgi: سريعة.
Logix Inc: ما فيها ال يفنت أجندة ما فيها ما فيها فيها
Logix Inc: هذه ممكن مع
Logix Inc: حنيجي لموضوع
Logix Inc: لكن ممكن،
Logix Inc: وينت
Logix Inc: لكن عندما تسيبهم انا شوف الموضوع الجاي حخليه ليميتد للسيستم.
Logix Inc: لن ادخل الموضوع لليوزرز
Logix Inc: لأنه
Logix Inc: حيكون في زي ما تقول كونسبتشن
Logix Inc: يكون في.
Adnan ishgi: استخدام عالي.
Logix Inc: أيوه أحد مثلا عارف يسوي جنرالات هذه كلها محسوبة بفلوس.
Adnan ishgi: واضح.
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: لسه الموضوع الجاي لسه برضو
Logix Inc: قف
Logix Inc: هنا خلاص قلنا موضوع اجندة سبيكرز
Logix Inc: نكست خلاص يوريك السمري نفس.
Adnan ishgi: إنت عملتلنا جدول هي ترى مرة جبارة الجدول مرة جبارة
Adnan ishgi: لأنها تمشي مع الهيئة الإقتصاد الصحية وما دام يطلبوا جداول.
Logix Inc: الأجندة هذه.
Adnan ishgi: وجبارة هذه
Adnan ishgi: ده حين اللي يشترك في ال يفنت يشوف الكلام ده ولا لأ.
Logix Inc: أيوة أيوة.
Adnan ishgi: جبار.
Logix Inc: أي حاجة
Logix Inc: اللي أنشأ الكورس
Logix Inc: يعني ما هي محطوطة على الفاضي زي ما تقول عارف.
Adnan ishgi: يعني.
Logix Inc: معروضة في الواجهة الرئيسية. طبعا هذه كلها.
Adnan ishgi: هاوي كومبيوتر هاوي كومبيو ديس فون.
Logix Inc: هذه كلها طبعا
Logix Inc: بليس هولدرز كلها آي ديفنت لينك ذي.
Adnan ishgi: لا نقصد، أقصد، الآن لل كورس هذا؟ كيف أنا أشوفه كيف منظرها حيطلع في في الكورسات.
Logix Inc: فهمتك برضه لسه ما اقولك انا شغال في المنطقة هذه في تشانجز
Logix Inc: هنا. هذا.
Adnan ishgi: يعني ما في جدول هذا ماني شك في جدول.
Logix Inc: أيوا لا لسه رح أضيف الجدول رح أضيف طبعا هنا هذه
Logix Inc: حتكون زي ما تقول
Logix Inc: زي هنا مثلا كورسيس يجي يروح على الكورس يعني مثلا فيو كورس
Logix Inc: برضو حتى شغل ديو هنا مختلف عن هناك
Logix Inc: لأنه آي ديدانت لينك تو داتا.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي وطب معلش بعد إذنك
Adnan ishgi: آه لو أنا بسوي شير في الواتساب مثلا كيف يعني إنت مثلا هذا سهل ولا لأ؟ هذا يهمني.
Logix Inc: في موضوع الشعر.
Adnan ishgi: مرة مرة يهمني هذا عارف إذا الحين أنا عندي الكورسات هذه
Adnan ishgi: اللي المؤقتة دي.
Logix Inc: من هنا نشوف.
Adnan ishgi: أيوه
Adnan ishgi: طب كيف يطلع.
Logix Inc: تكدر تسوي
Logix Inc: ايش صار
Logix Inc: بخير؟
Logix Inc: يعني حتى الشعر مرة ممتاز لأنه رابط كل
Logix Inc: الأنظمة.
Adnan ishgi: أنا شكله في الواتساب أيوا كيف شكله في الواتساب؟ ولا كيف شكله في
Adnan ishgi: كيف يطلع الشكل؟ انت عارف لانه لو هذا مثلا
Adnan ishgi: يسوي بروموشن للأبليكيشن لما عملنا ماركت بلان، على قد.
Logix Inc: زي مثلا هذا فيلم ميساجز.
Adnan ishgi: بس ما يطلع ما يطلع صور ما يطلع شيء.
Logix Inc: لا، لا، هذه هذا يعتبر من موضوع اللي هو يطلعلك الصور يطلعلك كل شي لكن لسه ما اشتغلت عليها.
Adnan ishgi: لا ده الحين مثلا ما أنا أجي أسوي شير لصورة لي في الإنستغرام أحطه في الواتساب يطلع صندوق بالصورة حقتي بعدين في كلام تحت.
Logix Inc: أيوة أيوة نفس ما سويت في هاوس دي ميكا.
Adnan ishgi: ايوه هذه إيوة؟ هل إنه. هذه
Adnan ishgi: هذه اللي تخلي الناس تحط تحط رجل على أبليكيشن.
Logix Inc: إمم.
Adnan ishgi: هذا اللي حيجيب الناس لمن أنا أنشر الكورسات بالطريقة دي ما عاد حينزل أبليكيشن ويسوي داونلود لما يشوفه طول الوقت كده كده كده ساعتها ممكن ينزلوا أبليكيشن.
Logix Inc: أنت عارف أصلا. أنا استخدمت لغة برمجية جديدة الموضوع
Logix Inc: لأنه هاوس فيستديو اكاديمي
Logix Inc: اضطريت أسوي شيء مانويل وحتى في لو مشاكل وفي اللينك ما تطلعلك الصورة؟ احيانا تطلعلك لكن هذا هذا اللغة البرمجية هو يعتبر ثريم وورك
Logix Inc: هذا الفريمورت مخصص لل
Logix Inc: للأمور هذه
Logix Inc: خلاص أول ما تسوي شير يطلعلك حتى مخصص برضه من ناحية
Logix Inc: اللي هو السوشيال
Logix Inc: ان جنبت الصين
Logix Inc: اللي هو لما تسوي لما تبحث عنه في غوغل يطلعلك جميع البيانات واحتمال يطلعلك أول 1 عشان
Logix Inc: الابتومازيشن دقيقة عارف.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي أوكي فهمت عليك
Adnan ishgi: فيفيد جدا في الأمور هذه
Adnan ishgi: مرة مرة والله
Adnan ishgi: طب جميل والله ترى أنا شايفها شي مرة حلو ما شاء الله
Adnan ishgi: من شافها شي مرة طمنتني والله
Adnan ishgi: سو إنت شغال على الكورسيس ديفينيشن حقك والإفنتس رايت نعم صح؟
Logix Inc: يس.
Adnan ishgi: طيب الإيفنت.
Logix Inc: ما خشيت.
Adnan ishgi: مو مشكلة ال يفنت الآن أنت الآن الإيفنت عبارة عن تواريخ وتحديد للإفنتس طيب لو مثلا 1 يسوي أونلاين يعني بسوي كورس أونلاين طيب
Adnan ishgi: هل الكورس أونلاين حيطلعني على زوم برا؟ هل في شي؟ أنا أقدر أسويه في تعاون مع زوم هل في اشتراك انه يكون الخدمة موجودة
Adnan ishgi: وال.
Logix Inc: ممكن يكون في هذا برضه أصلا حاطينو اللي هم هيئة التخصصات لا مو هيئة تخصصات ال
Logix Inc: اللي تصير معتمدين عندهم من الدولة.
Adnan ishgi: المركز الوطني للتعليم الإلكتروني.
Logix Inc: هم دول حاطين من الشروط انو لازم يكون في انتغريشن مع زوم أو
Logix Inc: المهم انه راح يكون في مثلا أوبشن أو
Logix Inc: زي ما تقول
Logix Inc: آه شو اسمها
Logix Inc: بادج زي كدا بادج انه فيرتوال.
Adnan ishgi: ولما يضغط يروح ينقلهم على الهدف.
Logix Inc: إيه لينك،
Adnan ishgi: بتعرف قديش إشتراكاتها ولا لأ.
Logix Inc: لا والله ما أعرف صراحة.
Adnan ishgi: طيب إنت الآن شغال على كورسيس بس كوميونيتيز لسه صح؟
Logix Inc: أم.
Adnan ishgi: وإيش الأصعب فيهم. انت شايف
Adnan ishgi: ولا
Adnan ishgi: كلهم زي بعض.
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: والله
Logix Inc: ما قصدك ما بين ال كورس والإفنت والكومي ولا كورس.
Adnan ishgi: يعني مثلا كورسيس.
Logix Inc: الكرة.
Adnan ishgi: طبعا.
Logix Inc: لأنه فيها فيديوز فيها ليسنس فيها كويز هذه اصعب طبعا معقدة أكثر.
Adnan ishgi: طيب لأنه لأنه أنا بس بحاول أحسب إنه نحنا من قبل رمضان بدأنا صح فبعرف مثلا
Adnan ishgi: ما تحش على الأشياء التانية. هل عندك فيزيز للونش إنت سويت بلان صحيح؟
Adnan ishgi: بس كان على أساس إنه أبليكيشن كله يكون كامل فهل نحنا ولا في تغيير يعني الحين إنت دخلت في المعمعة أنا بحاول أكون بس ريل معاك في النقاش عشان
Adnan ishgi: عشان نعرف نحنا كمان إيش إيش مواجهين احنا تحديات.
Logix Inc: ايوه انا حاط زي ما تقول ال تايم لاين كان على الثلاثين جون.
Adnan ishgi: صحيح؟
Logix Inc: لكن صراحة
Logix Inc: رح يكون في شوية تأخير ما أكتب عليك يعني أقولك من بدري.
Adnan ishgi: طيب متى تتوقع ترى مرة شوف هادي شوف هنا أبغاك تعطيني جهدك تعطينا تواريخ والله شوية محرج الموضوع بالنسبة لي مع الناس اللي برا،
Adnan ishgi: فأنا محتاج أعرف منك. عشان نطلع خطط أنا وإنت كيف نشغل الموضوع شوف إذا أنا.
Logix Inc: شوف حاولت أسوي زي ما تقول سوفت لونش على اللي اتفقنا عليه إنه عشان الكروز وكذا لكن ما قدرت ما لأنه لما تبي تسوي لونش إنت لازم يكون عندك شي جاهز
Logix Inc: لأنه ما تبغى اليوزر يخش بس يتفرج ويطلع فهذه ما هي حلوة صراحة.
Adnan ishgi: لا، لا.
Logix Inc: أقدر أقدر أسوي لونش على على وضعه كده يقدر يخش ال يوزر يشوف أوكي في كورسيس في
Logix Inc: في يفنت في كيمونيتي في مدري ايش
Logix Inc: لكن
Logix Inc: ما هي حلوة مع نت بروفيشنال زي ما تقول.
Ahmad Zahid: ممكن.
Logix Inc: يعني
Logix Inc: المستثمرين مثلا بس.
Ahmad Zahid: يوم.
Logix Inc: هذا شكل
Logix Inc: سيكون شكله كده مثلا أوكي أما
Logix Inc: إنه تسوي لانش لازم يكون جاهز في كلها جاهزة.
Logix Inc: انه خلاص اقدر ادخل اسوي
Logix Inc: كورسات تكدر تسوي يفنتس أقدر أسوي الأمور هذه.
Adnan ishgi: أتفق
Adnan ishgi: أتفق معك
Adnan ishgi: ولا.
Ahmad Zahid: طيب مرة ثانية كتاريخ يعني يخلص إنه فيرست
Ahmad Zahid: وهل ممكن. نعمل سوفت لونش عليهم؟ وبعدين نكمل الباقي اللي هي كومونيتيز وهكذا والبوست وال
Ahmad Zahid: ولا لأ لازم نخلص ال كوميونيتي والبوست رح يكون مرة صعب نسوي أبديت بعد سوفت لونش.
Logix Inc: تو ذي تايم لاين تو لانج إن شاء الله على الثلاثين جون
Logix Inc: لكن لو كان في تأخير سيكون ان شاء الله تأخير بسيط
Logix Inc: اسبوعين 3 بالكثير ان شاء الله
Logix Inc: أم
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: بالنسبة للكم سوفت لنش
Logix Inc: وأشتغل بعدين على يعني على الكوميونيتي والأمور هذه ما في مشكلة ان شاء الله
Logix Inc: لأن أنا شغال عليها يعني زي ما تقول الستروكتور موجود جاهز لكن ما فاضي زي ما تقول زي كده تخش للديسكاشنز مثلا
Logix Inc: صفحة فاضية لكن
Logix Inc: الباك اند
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: مربوطة ألريدي.
Adnan ishgi: واضح واضح. أقولك معلش بس أنا عشان لا أنسى جوتها الإثنين صح؟ تقسمهم ولا ما حد تقسمهم اللي هي الكورسيس ما شاف الليفين سنة.
Logix Inc: أم
Logix Inc: لا؟ هذه لسه. ما هي الشكل النهائي.
Adnan ishgi: طيب خلاص خلاص معليش الآن أنا بتخيل الآن اليوم أنا بتكلم معاك لأني بفكر لما يجتمع مع الناس إيش حيسووا جيت أنا اليوم جلست مع شركة وقالوا إحنا نبغى نسوي إفنتات عن طريق أبليكيشن حقهم حلو
Adnan ishgi: حيقولوا لي بان نحن عملنا يفنترو أبليكيشن
Adnan ishgi: الناس بدأت تشتري تسجل حلو.
Logix Inc: اي.
Adnan ishgi: طيب إيش هم يشوف إيش حقهم هم إيش عندهم؟ هل يشوفوا الدخل اللايف تسجيل هالأشياء إيش اللي يصير.
Logix Inc: أم
Logix Inc: تمام حلو آه أنا عشان كدا سويت هذا يعتبر داش بورت خاص بمكان ما وريتكم الآن كريات كورس كريات هذا داش بورت خاص
Logix Inc: زي ما تقول سوبسكرايب يوزرز أو
Logix Inc: سوبسكرايب سواء يوزرز ولا
Logix Inc: يكون في داش بورد احصائيات منسجل كم عدد المسجلين وإحصائيات للكورس نفسه
Logix Inc: كم 1 كم اندرال للكورس كمراد للإفنت
Logix Inc: احصائيات
Logix Inc: المبيعات مثلا
Logix Inc: كم يعني مبيعات الكورس هذا كم مبيعات الافنت.
Adnan ishgi: يعني في يعني كل 1.
Adnan ishgi: المنصة حقة كورساتو.
Logix Inc: أم.
Adnan ishgi: صح؟ هذا.
Logix Inc: هذا داش بورد زي ما تقول
Logix Inc: برضو يعتبر.
Adnan ishgi: شي.
Logix Inc: يعني احتمال يكون نفس الطريقة،
Logix Inc: لكن في، حيكون في تغييرات كثيرة جدا. لكن هذه يعني هذا
Logix Inc: الله
Logix Inc: طيب.
Adnan ishgi: الداش بورد مالو حق إنو هو يسوي ريفاند صح إحنا منسوي ولا كيف.
Logix Inc: لا، أنا قلت لأحمد زاهد. إنه.
Adnan ishgi: أنا ما بام يسووا ريفاند معليش أنا خايف يتلاعبوا يسووا كورس ويسووا ريفاند رايحة لناس وهميين والله ماني عارف شو ممكن يصير إيش رأيك.
Logix Inc: أم
Logix Inc: صح فعلا في
Logix Inc: نعم،
Logix Inc: موضوع التلاعب من أي ناحية لأنه هذه سموها
Logix Inc: اللي هو يوزر بيهافيور.
Logix Inc: انت ما تدري 600,001 حيخش ما تدري البهيبر حقهم كيف حيكون كل 1 حيكون مختلف عن الثاني فأنت لازم.
Adnan ishgi: هي.
Logix Inc: الحساب،
Logix Inc: يجب
Logix Inc: جميع الاحتمالات.
Adnan ishgi: يكون عندهم مثلا بس ما يقدر يسوي ريفاند بس يجينا إيميل.
Logix Inc: يسوي ريكويست مثلا.
Adnan ishgi: حاجزي كدا.
Adnan ishgi: الفلوس ما بقى عليها كنترول أبوهم بس أوبزير صراحة بس ما في كونترول.
Logix Inc: ا
Logix Inc: طيب تمام.
Adnan ishgi: في البدايات لما نوصل مرحلة نكون كويسين
Adnan ishgi: ممكن أسأل شي سؤال في المستقبل تنام في المستقبل.
Adnan ishgi: إحنا عندنا مستقبل قريب طبعا مو بعيد إحنا عندنا 4 منها البوستات صح إنه مثلا يعني البوستات دي جينيراتيد من كوميونيتي ترى ممكن تكون أوتوماتيك يعني أنا أقولك
Adnan ishgi: البوستات نازلة زي الإنستغرام ممكن وحدة منا تكون عبارة عن ممكن تكون وحدة منا كورس
Adnan ishgi: طيب في البوستات يحطها في كوستير للبوست
Adnan ishgi: هل إحنا في مجال في المستقبل؟ لما نضيف دعاية في البوست يعني مثلا أنا أبغى كل 1 يفك البوست يفك حقه يلاقي دعاية لكوست معين يصير أنا أقدر أنشر كورسي الكورس حقي في كل ال على حقهم.
Logix Inc: أيوا شوف هذي هنا اللي جاي يخش
Logix Inc: اها.
Adnan ishgi: هنا يجي موضوع.
Logix Inc: الاشياء اللي انت كلها بتقول عليها هنا اللي جاي جدا مفيد فيها.
Adnan ishgi: بس أنا بس بس أنا الدعاية يهمني آي كان جيت ماني أوتوفيت يعني هم هل أقدر أضيف بعدين أوبشن حق.
Logix Inc: آه أوكي أوكي يعني قصدك أنت
Logix Inc: آه فهمت عليك، فهمت عليك
Logix Inc: يس وي كان دو ذات.
Adnan ishgi: طيب إنت حط ببالك الأشياء دي لما تيجي بعدين أقولك هي الآن أنا همني الآن عندي فور فون شغالة حيكون وورك أونيت ونقدر نسويله سوفت لانش
Adnan ishgi: في أقرب وقت ممكن تقدر عليه، وأنا أقدر أستخدم الانترفيس هذا أجلس مع الناس أوريهم. آه أبدأ أسوي فيرشن ولا وات يفرج يسمونه أجيب ناس يشتغلوا يسووا كورسات عندنا عند الناس أقدر أجيبها
Adnan ishgi: وبعد كده ما يهمني الفيد باك اللي يجي التعديلات هذه ما يهمني نسويها بعدين نكمل فورا بس آي نيد سومثينج تانجابل حاجة حاجة محسوسة.
Logix Inc: دش
Logix Inc: إمهم
Logix Inc: هادي
Logix Inc: السلام عليكم
Logix Inc: هلا والله.
Ahmad Zahid: إحنا على المقاطعة بس أنا جاني
Ahmad Zahid: فرنش
Ahmad Zahid: ويعني
Ahmad Zahid: يعملوا لي أشعة
Ahmad Zahid: آي لوجاوت يعني
Ahmad Zahid: إذا كنتم.
Logix Inc: طبعا ما عندك مشكلة.
Ahmad Zahid: هذا أرجع أدخل طيب
Ahmad Zahid: طيب آه أرسلكم في الجروب أحسنت
Ahmad Zahid: طيب
Ahmad Zahid: مع السلامة.
Adnan ishgi: طيب ماشي.
Logix Inc: أوكي
Logix Inc: آه اللي جاي انا بالنسبة لي يعني يعتبر زي ما تقول لسه مبتدئ فيه
Logix Inc: لكن
Logix Inc: يعني طبعا لما تقول
Logix Inc: شيء
Logix Inc: ولما تسوي انتغريشن مع سيستم شي ثاني
Logix Inc: في مرة عارف
Logix Inc: إلى.
Adnan ishgi: في.
Adnan ishgi: حتى العيال كل.
Logix Inc: أيوا
Logix Inc: فهنا في شيء اسمه يعني زي مثلا البعثة اللي حقة الكورسات حقة ال يفنت كلها يصير لها ستور
Logix Inc: داتا بيس الداتا بيس. هذه تعتبر لغة برمجية اسمها
Logix Inc: حلو لكن بالنسبة لأي يستخدم شي اسمه تالكينز
Logix Inc: و
Logix Inc: وال داتا بيس حقتها خاصة فيها يعني
Logix Inc: هي اللي يبنوا عليها لانجواج نفسه اللي هي ال إم هذه
Logix Inc: فإحنا نقدر نسوي أور أونلاين ويج نموذج
Logix Inc: زي هنا لو تلاحظ اكسبرس ميني لانجواج
Logix Inc: ليسنس ميني لانجواج في تو
Logix Inc: هذه ايش فايدتها
Logix Inc: هي تعتبر إيش زي ما تقول كوليكشن
Logix Inc: الكوليكشن هذا
Logix Inc: أم.
Adnan ishgi: أيوة.
Logix Inc: دقيقة بالله دكتور
Logix Inc: التحدي
Logix Inc: الله يسلمك
Logix Inc: آه.
Adnan ishgi: سوري هيك.
Logix Inc: هنا موضوع لانجواج التي تعتبر دوكومنتس
Logix Inc: هاند كوليكشن
Logix Inc: نحن لما مثلا
Logix Inc: انت مثلا سويت كورس كورس حقك الكونتينت فيه تاتل ديسكريبشن
Logix Inc: التاتل والديسكريبشن هذه انت تضيفها في كوليكشن هذه
Logix Inc: بناء عليها لما مثلا احد يخش على
Logix Inc: كورسي
Logix Inc: حلو أنا سويت كورس وخش على كورس حقي.
Adnan ishgi: أيوة.
Logix Inc: مثلا يبدا اللي هو نقول إنه ديكورد مثلا.
Adnan ishgi: طيب.
Logix Inc: أو حتى يفنت ينفع
Logix Inc: يدرس مثلا يحضر المحاضرات كلها ويسويز الأمور هذه خلاص خلص
Logix Inc: مثلا تجيلو بيت
Logix Inc: دكتور عدنان سكورس لانه تايتل حقه أو ديسكريبشن حقه
Logix Inc: سام هاو ريليتيد تو ماي كورس أو كورس تايتل أور ماي كورس ديسكريبشن عارف.
Logix Inc: هذه اللي هي نفس التكنولوجيا اللي غوغل يستخدموها
Logix Inc: الكبيرة اللي تستخدمها.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي.
Logix Inc: لأنه ما
Logix Inc: يعني فكرته هم دائما يعطوا مثال أنا عشان أقرأ يعطوا مثال مثلا
Logix Inc: بهامس واورنت ايش العلاقة بينهم
Logix Inc: انت لما تفكر لما تبحث عن بهامس.
Adnan ishgi: ما حد يطلعلك أورانج في نتائج البحث.
Logix Inc: لكن هذا، يعتبر عيالي، فهو ذكي كفاية انه يربط ما بين الاثنين
Logix Inc: ثي نوبل
Logix Inc: أن
Logix Inc: فيهاربط ما بين.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي.
Logix Inc: هذا الشيء جدا حلو يعني رح يفيد في أشياء مرة كثير
Logix Inc: متأدي.
Adnan ishgi: فكرة وحدة بالنسبة لي بحس. إنها ممكن تكون مفيدة صراحة.
Logix Inc: إيش.
Adnan ishgi: آه
Adnan ishgi: أم
Adnan ishgi: أنا سؤالي. أول شيء هذا الإي آي عندنا لما أنت تقولي كريت لانجواج ويمكن تمشي مع اليسار لما تقول كريت لاندواج هل تبي تقنعني جوت ال سيستم يتعلم مع الوقت
Adnan ishgi: جودة التطبيق بتقصده.
Logix Inc: إمهم.
Adnan ishgi: سوف. هل ممكن.
Logix Inc: ذات ريليتيد تو ألورز
Logix Inc: تو إكسبيرت
Logix Inc: ايت ويل ليرن أوز ايت غولث كروز.
Adnan ishgi: لأنه لأنه أنا لإنه أنا أتمنى أنا يعني وحدة من الأهداف اللي كان نفسي أوصلها قبل ما يكون في صراحة.
Logix Inc: إنه يكون أنا الموقع حقنا ريلاي ويل سورس أوف إنفورميشن.
Adnan ishgi: طيب.
Logix Inc: إمم.
Adnan ishgi: فمثلا عندي صح
Adnan ishgi: ولا عندنا مكان حق الأسئلة مثلا يعني يمكن الإي آي في صار ممكن يصير في تكس
Adnan ishgi: فهل من أجوبة الناس البروفيشنال يعني كل مرة مثلا ويتش لانغ ويجي كاليوز مثلا ديلفي ولا بيسك ولا سي بلوس بلوس ولا اللغات اللي فيه فمثلا كل الأي تي اختاروا سي بلوس بلوس يصير بعد كده اللي يسأل ممكن الإي آي يعطي له إجابة
Adnan ishgi: يقولوا هذه غالبا لأنو أنا نفسي في الأخير إذا نحنا عندنا كوميونيتي جلس 5 6 سنوات في دينك أنسورز للناس يمكن الإي آي آي باي كده يصير هو غلط كلامي.
Logix Inc: لأ شوف أنا فكرت فيها
Logix Inc: إنه بس ما رح نقدر نستخدم بالطريقه اللي انت يعني اللي بتقول عليها.
Adnan ishgi: لأنه الموضوع كله في النهاية.
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: يعني تدريس لو تدخل الموضوع سيكون غش
Logix Inc: فاهم كيف.
Adnan ishgi: أم.
Logix Inc: فهمت قصدي.
Adnan ishgi: فهمت
Adnan ishgi: طيب.
Logix Inc: والله أنا فكرت في الموضوع هذا لأنه
Logix Inc: يعني مثلا اليوزر يقدر اصلا حتى
Logix Inc: الجهة الحكومية اللي تعطي التصاريح هادي
Logix Inc: ذاكرين إنه لازم يكون في حاجة تمنع الغش هذه للآن أنا صراحة ما ما أدري كيف أسويها.
Adnan ishgi: لا ما نحط بكل بساطة.
Logix Inc: لكن أنا قصدي في الترانينغ الترينج طبعا حيكون
Logix Inc: فيري فيري بيسك
Logix Inc: انت تسويلو فيد للانفورميشن
Logix Inc: أكدت إكسبرس
Logix Inc: هو يرد
Logix Inc: بناء على إنفورميشن هذا ما يطلع عنا
Logix Inc: زي لمن كانوا يحاولوا
Logix Inc: يقول مثلا يارا
Logix Inc: الامور هذه ايش كانوا يسووا يحطوا ايش يحطوا
Logix Inc: يسموها شرب
Logix Inc: كونتكت إنو تقول حتى لو قالوا كدا
Logix Inc: ما ترد كدا عارف انت ترد كده زي كده هذه فكرة.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي
Adnan ishgi: طيب حكاية والله يبغالي يفكر فيها والله لأنه موضوع كله خايف
Adnan ishgi: خايف أحطه بعدين نفسي أحطه بطريقة منيمان ما يكلفني أستخدمه. كماركت مو أكثر من كده كبداية بعدين كده أشوف كيف أشوف أنا مقتنع إني ما أبغى؟ أغني الأشياء كلها كبداية أقول موجودة،
Adnan ishgi: لكن هذا فيرجينيا الجديدة في التحديثات الجديدة. تيجي بس أنا حين أطلق المشروع صراحة مرة مرة يا أحمد أبي أطلق المشروع خلاص أنا يعني أنا أنا يعني كنت لا أتقبل موضوع إني أتأخر عن 20 25 بس لمن جيت إنت أقنعتني صراحة إني أخر
Adnan ishgi: وحقيقة أنا دايما أقول يعني يمكن لو أطلقتو انت جيت حيكون توليت لأي حاجة
Adnan ishgi: بس أنا أنا حاليا دحين نفسي أطلق من غير ما عقد الدنيا عشان لا تزيد تكاليف وتزيد الشغل ويزيد ويزيد أبغى أطلق الموضوع وأبدأ أستفيد منه تدريجيا يا راجل بعد كده أحطك في البورد معانا حتى في التوسعة في النقاشات في يعني هذا مشروع ترى يأكلنا كلنا يعني صراحة كنا نحنا وإنت
Adnan ishgi: عشان كبرت تكسب كمان نكبر ونوسع ونحط مشاريع جديدة تطلعلنا فواتير جديدة بس أنا محتاج كمان اتأكد انه المشروع. بدأ تدفع فلوس بيزيد فلوس.
Logix Inc: صحيح؟ اشتغلت.
Adnan ishgi: آه الأكاديمية مشاريع سوينا كروز دحين عندنا مشاريع تانية فالحين عندنا فلوس يسوي بس أنا ما أقدر أجي من البداية مشاريع نفس التطبيق
Adnan ishgi: فحاس إني أنا فقط حاليا بس التطبيق بسبوس فلوس بدفع وما في شي وبيني وبينك الناس كل ما تأخرنا كل ما يقولوا لأ شكلو عندك مشكلة
Adnan ishgi: ف
Adnan ishgi: وجهة نظري، إني أنا نفسي أطلق. المشروع يكون ما في بوكس كثير صراحة يكون زي ما وريتني تكون الأربع 5 شغالة تقولي مينيمم أقللك البوستات لحاجة معينة ما عندي مشكلة تقول لي تايم ما عندي مشكلة أنا حكون معاك منطقي لأبعد الدرجة العكس أدعم ال فيشين حقتك إنت واضح عندك شي أكبر من اللي عندنا صراحة
Adnan ishgi: بس كمان أعطيني شي كبيزنس مان أعطيني شي أشغله
Adnan ishgi: أعطيني حاجة
Adnan ishgi: أقدر أشد فيها يعني كلام الناس زي ما يقولوا.
Logix Inc: أم
Logix Inc: بإذن الله.
Adnan ishgi: يعني إنت صراحة أنا بالنسبة لي تقريبا شفت أشياء مطمئنة بس شوية حاجة تلقاني حاسس
Adnan ishgi: عشان طبيعة العمل ما هو انتقاد ولا شي بس حاسس انو
Adnan ishgi: ما هو 60 في المية حاسس إنه أقل من 60 في المية التخلص يعني عندي إحساس اللي شفته 30 أو 40 في المية. إنه لسه في الداش بورد واللينك ولسه في الكوميونيتي.
Logix Inc: لا في حاجات كثير ما ما عندك هنا؟ هذه ك آي دي اف لانه زي ما تقول
Logix Inc: مثل ما تقول واجهت معضله انه
Logix Inc: يعني انت تبي تعرض بيج سواء اللاندينغ بيج أو
Logix Inc: داش فورد بطريقة معينة حسب
Logix Inc: المستخدم حسب اليوزر.
Adnan ishgi: حلو.
Logix Inc: سيكون مثلا جائتني فكرة انه يكون مثلا بيج زي
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: توداي.
Adnan ishgi: 1 أطرد 1 يبغى أكثر من شي.
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: في هنا أوبشن
Logix Inc: هذه برضو.
Adnan ishgi: دومي كونتن تعرف ما هي
Adnan ishgi: أوكي أوكي
Adnan ishgi: حلو.
Logix Inc: كرجمنت
Logix Inc: كان في
Logix Inc: ون ونش لأ كان في أول أوبشن هنا.
Logix Inc: إنه
Logix Inc: بوز
Logix Inc: فرنسية.
Adnan ishgi: أو شيء.
Logix Inc: يا يا
Logix Inc: يكون في هون بوردينغ
Logix Inc: التوبيكس اللي راح يعلمه على اساس يختار توبيكس معينة
Logix Inc: خلاص مثلا ال اي اي يساعده في اختيار تايتزكريبشن
Logix Inc: كفكرة عموما يعني مو شرط.
Adnan ishgi: والله فنان والصورة ده فكرة كويسة والله.
Logix Inc: بس عربي بس إنجليزي بناء مثلا بناء على اللانغز اللي يختارها
Logix Inc: نعرض المنصة بشكل عام طبعا يقدر يغير لو يريد عربي او انجليزي
Logix Inc: لكن مثلا خلي
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: بشكل عام انه كتفضيل العربي اكثر من الانجليزي أو الانجليزي اكثر من العربي.
Adnan ishgi: حلو.
Logix Inc: إنجاجمنت.
Adnan ishgi: شوف هذه
Adnan ishgi: كل
Adnan ishgi: شوف أنا بالنسبة لي. دي الحين كرياتي كونتينت نفسها واتشين كورسيس
Adnan ishgi: شفت إحنا بس إحنا إحنا يمكن.
Logix Inc: في لخبطة هنا.
Adnan ishgi: أنا أنا ما عندي مشكلة في البداية الناس تتلخبط بس نحنا كشركة.
Logix Inc: لازم يكون التوجه واضح.
Adnan ishgi: أيوه يصيروا هم مع الوقت يتعلموا.
Logix Inc: أيواه.
Adnan ishgi: بس أنا خايف. إنه هذه لازم تكون ماشية مع الويب سايت ماشية مع أبليكيشن ماشية مع كل العام
Adnan ishgi: لا.
Logix Inc: طبعا لازم لازم تكون ماشية ولا غير كده حيكون في مشاكل في أبليكيشن نفسه عارف.
Adnan ishgi: إحنا إحنا ما عملنا كوتشينج ولا توترينغ تويتر الناس تقول صعب نطقها وصعب كدا كوتشينج يقولك العكس كويس إنه هذا تدريب لي خلاص مسجلة وكريات بس ممكن أخليها كورسيس فاين بس أجين إحنا ما إخترنا كورسيس عشان كورسيس داخلة من ضمن ال يفنتس كمان
Adnan ishgi: رسمناها بالشكل ده فقلنا يمكن في الوقت في الأول الواحد ما يتقبلوها بس مع الوقت مع الوقت مع الوقت حيعدولك خلص لا كوتشينج معروفة كوتشينج عبارة عن ملخص عبارة عن فيديو مسجل عبارة عن حتحطوه بس هذا هو الكوتشينج يعني أنا آخد أشياء مسجلة والإيفنت اللي هو يشمل حاجات، اللايف سواء أون لاين ولا ولا فيزيكال.
Logix Inc: أم
Logix Inc: شوف هنا برضو في اليوزر بروفايل. أنا حاولت أشتغل كثير على الواجهة الرئيسية لليوزر.
Adnan ishgi: حلو.
Logix Inc: لأنه سيكون في زي يعني فكرة اللي هو السوشيال
Logix Inc: يكون في فولو
Logix Inc: أند فولو والأمور هذه
Logix Inc: يعني هنا الأوفر ديو حق البروفايل حق يوزر كم كورس كومبليتيد
Logix Inc: أورز ليرن
Logix Inc: في موضوع الليفلز
Logix Inc: إمم.
Adnan ishgi: في تعز
Adnan ishgi: حاجة كان إسمها ما أعرف أنا شفت هذا الموضوع اللي موجود عندنا
Adnan ishgi: كان.
Logix Inc: وإيش.
Adnan ishgi: هو إيش اللي في فرينز في فرينز وأند فريندز صح
Adnan ishgi: في حاجة إسمها إيش يعني هو شي ولا بس إحنا سويناه صراحة في ال
Adnan ishgi: ، لنفرض أنا ما بتابعك حلو
Adnan ishgi: بس إنت عملتلي كومنت جاوبتلي على سؤال دخلت وحدة من كورساتي اللي هو سميه.
Adnan ishgi: حيسجلك ب 1
Adnan ishgi: فالفكرة كلها والفيديو النمبير هاو ميني بيبول ذي أبروتش ريغار نيو ولا لأ
Adnan ishgi: فحتلاقي الرقم ده كبير مرة يعني مثلا لو أنا الحين في الإنستغرام، أنا عندي 7,000 فور حلو.
Logix Inc: أم.
Adnan ishgi: أنا متأكد لو بحسب كمية الناس اللي دخلت حطتلي كومن أو لايك أو شافت ستوري أو أو أي حاجة وي ديفينيت. أنا متأكد يمكن عندي مية 1,000.
Logix Inc: مو كل دول بتابعوني.
Adnan ishgi: فهو يعطي انطباع هاو ماتش بيبول
Adnan ishgi: الرقم ده يزيد بطريقة متسارعة تحمس الناس سيكولوجي إنه والله
Adnan ishgi: لأن في كثير ناس يسووا محتوى مرة كثير تلاقي عنده 500 بس
Adnan ishgi: بس حقيقي المحتوى حقهم في ناس كثير زي الموقع حقه شافوه فشوي يعطيلو دفعة معنوية إنه ما احتجت على العكس هذا يوريك قديش هو انتشر يفري وير زي الأرقام اللي أشوفها مثلا في تويتر لمن أعلن يقول مثلا 50,000 إمبريشن يو نو راني يعني هذا هذا عملناه صراحة في في أبليكيشن
Adnan ishgi: آه كانت حلوة كانت يعني أنا عندي 3 بس كان يمكن في عندي اثنعشر شخص، فإحنا ما كان عندنا ناس مشتكين في التطبيق. أنا بس بيت جدات مدخنين أو 1,000 حتى كلهم لا ذي إنتراكتيد بس مو كلهم فاضوني.
Logix Inc: صحيح؟
Adnan ishgi: أنا ما أعرف هذا؟ هذا؟ شيء سهل ولا هذا فيلم يعني برضه شوف هذه الأشياء حط في بالك وأنا لما نلعب على اللي هو الموال ده الناس كلها الآن تتكلم أنا عندي 4 ألاف فلورا عندي يعني
Adnan ishgi: فلما أنا أعطي رقم زي كده يمكن الناس تنسى موضوع الفالو والآن فالو يمكن هذا ما يصير في البرنامج يمكن برنامج إنتيراكشن يمكن ناس بعد كده ما تقول عندي 4 أصحاب حيقول والله أنا عندي إنترأكشن 50,000
Adnan ishgi: أنا موقعي الموقع حقي
Adnan ishgi: فهمت شخصية.
Logix Inc: يس.
Adnan ishgi: هذه من الأشياء الصراحة اللي اللي صراحة طلبناها وي فيلد ايت وورك بصراحة وي فيلث وورك.
Logix Inc: بس
Logix Inc: أي آي سوت هاي شفت ال
Logix Inc: بس كانت مبهمة بالنسبة لي ايش معنى الرقم ده.
Adnan ishgi: أقولك على حاجة أنا يعني بالهدوء لما جاء كلمني قيصر في الأخير على المشروع هو كان بدرلي الموضوع. بس أنا أكثر من تيم أشتغله. هذه الغلطة اللي سويت إنه أكثر من تيم أشتغل
Adnan ishgi: آخر شيء التيم اللي جابه
Adnan ishgi: صراحة كإنه صار في ديكلاين. أو كأنه جبلي ناس أرخص فكان في فلوس بقيت صراحة فأنا قلتلو بكل صدق وأمانة قلت له قيصر يو نايم أند نمبر قلتله أنا دفعتلك هاي الفلوس وما دفعتله دفعتله كثير
Adnan ishgi: يو نايم ذي نمبر اللي تحتاجه مني ليرضوا الله ويرضيك ويرضي
Adnan ishgi: والله قلي كده أنا ما كملتلك الدنيا قالي. أنا الفلوس الباقية لا تدفعها
Adnan ishgi: وأنا حكلم تيم لأن تيم من عندي في الدنيا سو أنا أقلك شغالة بس كانت فيها مشاكل عأساس نعدلها. فقلت لي نوت
Adnan ishgi: قلتله والله ما أعرف خلاص خليها كده خيرة أدوك لما تخيلت لما إنت قلتلي ما ينفع أشتغل معاهم
Adnan ishgi: وخلاص رميت الفلوس حقتك كلها معاك وسبحان الله جت من من عنده هو كده ما دفعتله الدفعة الأخيرة
Adnan ishgi: من عنده قلت ما قلتله أنا ما حدفعله قلت له أسمي الرقم وأنا أدفع. بس قلت له يرضي الله و يرضيك ويرضيني وكان صراحة أمين في النقاش حقه قال لي والله عدنان وقلي عندي مشكلة من عندي هو اعترف وهو كان فيها يبغاله شغل بس إحتمال أنا عندي إحساس إن هم عشان أكثر من تيم
Adnan ishgi: وكل 1 بخبص فوق التاني فكان شغل فيمكن وصلنا مرحلة إنه ديد كل شي داخل في بعض
Adnan ishgi: بس دايما أقول ربنا سبحان الله الواحد نيته طيب ل 1 ربنا يفتحله الناس قدامه فإنت لما جيت
Adnan ishgi: سمعتني كلام إنت ما إنت عارف أنا بمر بظروف إيش سمعت الكلام؟ عجبني أسوي أعمل وإشتغلت في الأكاديمية كويس وعلى فكرة في مشروع تاني كمان
Adnan ishgi: بس بعد ما خلص الموضوع، ده للتسجيل احتمال في مشروع ثالث اليوم تناقشنا فيه على أساس إنه ممكن زي إنت حابب تمسك مشروع ثالث يعني المشروع الثالث عبارة عن زي صيانة وأشياء زي كدا مو شغل كثير يعني
Adnan ishgi: فممكن بعد ما نخلص المية ميغا.
Logix Inc: مثل.
Adnan ishgi: طيب يعني إذا ما في شيء إضافي، هو أنا قلتلك كل حاجة إنت عندك شي تاني ولا هو هذه الاشياء خلاص.
Logix Inc: لا هذه الأشياء. أنا برضه أوريك زي ما تقولوا تقريبا
Logix Inc: بروكس
Logix Inc: بشكل عام أنا ليش قلت 65 في المية
Logix Inc: هذه اللي قلتلك عليها أول ثري سكشنز كور فيتشرز إنفراستروكتور دادا يعني شايف انت كل اغلبها.
Adnan ishgi: أم.
Logix Inc: لكن في في أنجزت أشياء كثيرة.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي.
Logix Inc: يعني
Logix Inc: آه
Logix Inc: يعني ان شاء الله الباقي كله ساعات بإذن الله.
Adnan ishgi: يا رب يا رب يا رب أقولك إنت
Adnan ishgi: أعطيني شي أشتغل عليه
Adnan ishgi: أنا عندي بجهتي يعني قلتلي سيرفر جديد إيديكيتد هل لازم سرفر جديد انت شايف.
Logix Inc: ايوه لازم صراحة لأنه أنا الآن اللي حاطه هذا حاطه مع نفس السعر فمسوي ضغط هناك مع على انه احنا رفعنا الرامات والأمور هذه. قبل فترة لكن برضو يعتبر لو أحط هذا مع خلاص ما عاد يشتغل
Logix Inc: طيب.
Adnan ishgi: الكلام ده طب السيرفر دا اللي هو منيوم عشان الدعاية صح.
Logix Inc: أساس تقدر تخش انت تشوف التحديثات ايش صار ايش ما صار الامور هذه تبغى توري مثلا المستثمرين تبي توريهم يعني يصير عندك خلاص صورة بشكل مستمر أما الآن ما رح ما رح اقدر اوريك اي شي لان انا شغال على ما في اي حاجة.
Adnan ishgi: أسمع آه طب أسمع لو إنه لو إنه إنت قلتلي
Adnan ishgi: إحنا إنت قلتلي نهاية جول ما تقدر تتأخر لو نحنا قلنا
Adnan ishgi: لو قلنا مثلا ثالث أسبوع في الجولاي ولا لو حطيتها يومين بعدها مو مشكلة أم إيش تكون خلصت معلش يعني كده خليك واقعي معايا عشان أنا كمان أقدر آخذ قرارات معاك.
Logix Inc: أنا الآن تركيزي كله رح ألغي كل الاشياء لانه انا زي مثلا
Logix Inc: زي مثلا هو صراحة الفترة الأسبوعين الثلاث اسابيع اللي راحت كلها شغالة في موضوع
Logix Inc: لكن خلاص زي ما تقول هو جاهز هو موجود، لكن خلاص حخليه على جنب
Logix Inc: ركز زي ما قلت في البداية
Logix Inc: أركز في موضوع الكورسيس أخلصها بشكل نهائي لأنه خلاص أقدر أنا أخش أسوي ببليش كورس أسوي
Logix Inc: حركز برضو في موضوع ال
Logix Inc: اللي هو البلان بيست سوبسكريبشن
Logix Inc: هذه جدا ضرورية أصلا عشان أقدر أسوي ببليش
Logix Inc: وول إيفنت.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي
Adnan ishgi: سو، أنا عندي.
Logix Inc: يعني هذه الثلاث أشياء لو خلصت
Logix Inc: أقدر نقدر نسوي ببليش على طول
Logix Inc: وبعد هكذا يعني نخش في الأشياء الثانية نربط مع الأمور هذه
Logix Inc: نربط موضوع اللايف سيشنز الزوم يعني في اشياء كثير في اشياء مره كثيرة اخرى.
Adnan ishgi: طيب يعني يعني إنت لمن جلاي يعني نص جولاي أو تلات أسبوع أو واتيفر فقط كورسيس وكميتي ما واو.
Logix Inc: والبلان.
Adnan ishgi: وال سوبسكوب جاهز طبعا لا تكون جاهز، صح؟
Logix Inc: معاهم مع الكورسيس والفينت.
Adnan ishgi: أوكي.
Logix Inc: على طول بعدها إن شاء الله
Logix Inc: وإحتمال يعني لو لو في وقت إنه
Logix Inc: اسم تاني سلي
Logix Inc: رح تكون لانه يعني تعتبر هي مهمة وبشكل ما مربوطه. مع لكن
Logix Inc: لو إنه حتأخرني لأ حخليها القدام.
Adnan ishgi: طيب عشان دوبي شفت معاك الموقع شوية فوق صراحة حاسس إنه شوية. ملخبطة فأنا، يمكن ما أبغى أسوي الآن ديديكيت تسافر.
Logix Inc: قصدك
Logix Inc: هذه.
Adnan ishgi: اي ايوا هذول الاتنين كده حاسس ما اعرف.
Logix Inc: أيوة أيوة.
Adnan ishgi: يعني الناس تكون مثلا أو لازم تعطينا فكرة إنكم متفقين عليها.
Logix Inc: بس كده ماني شايفة تلخبط الناس صراحة.
Adnan ishgi: لير.
Logix Inc: هذه لسه لسه هذه حاطها بشكل على أساس حأعدل عليها. لسه ما هي الشكل النهائي لسه.
Adnan ishgi: يعني يكون هي هي قلتلك هي هون عندنا في التطبيق. هون انت عندك اي افكار تانية ويا
Adnan ishgi: آه بس لازم نوحد كلامنا عشان ما نتكلم مع الناس ما أغير بس الكلام وكل البيزنتيشنز اللي عملتها على فور فرومشنز هاي ترى
Adnan ishgi: ألريدي إحنا بعثنا في كثير في الموضوع ده فأي أفكار عندك اللي تحت ما يهمني تحطلي ديسكاشن جروب ممتاز ثانك يو فيري ماتش لأي مخترع بس أنا أتكلم إنه 4 وظايف رئيسية واضحة البوست الهوم عبارة عن سيماري لكل شي تريبت يعني مثلا عندك كورس يقوم في بوست عملت كوميونيتي بوست عندك عارف أوتوماتيكلي إنت حبيت تسوي بوست معين تسوي بوست معين إنت عندك هذا حق كل 1
Adnan ishgi: أم يعني يمكن عبارة عن كوليكشن لكل شي تبي تسويه أتوقع حاجة زي كده
Adnan ishgi: يمكن هذا أسهل 1 قالولنا 1 ولا لأ بس هم يمكن هذا اللي احنا شايفينه
Adnan ishgi: فهذا يمكن لمن يجهز لما يجهز ديكي مثلا فوق يمكن أفضل ساعتها بقولك يلا نروح ديديكيتد سيرفر ونبدأ الشغل وندفع ما عنده مشكلة بس اليوم اليوم.
Logix Inc: تبغى تشوف وكده فقلت لك لازم. لكن أنا عن نفسي
Logix Inc: تطوير على لوكالوب. وبعدين نشوف موضوع ال ديفيكل.
Adnan ishgi: أول ما تحس إنه أنت مثلا جاهز إنت من كده تقديرك تقولي عدنان والله المستثمرين يشوفوا نقوم نجتمع ونشوف مع بعض الموضوع والله في شغالة حتى لو جزئيا أقول لك يا عمي أبدأ سرفر على طول ووريني إديني خليني أجتمع مع الناس ما عندي مشكلة.
Logix Inc: تمام.
Adnan ishgi: طيب معلش لأنه صار في تغييرات زي ما إنت شايف في التايم. لاين. هل ممكن بس كده ببساطة نسوي أبديت عاللي أرسلته منها التطبيق كمان لأني أنا فاكر يوم ما تكلمنا على أساس إنه لو بدأنا أيامها في ديسمبر. إنه على دون نخلص كل شي بالتطبيق بس إحنا بدأنا متأخر وأتوقع شكله الموضوع أطول من ما حسبناها صح كده تعملي أبديت تايم لاين
Adnan ishgi: ويبغاك تعرف حاجة يا أحمد يو أر يعني إنت رقبتك معانا في الموضوع ثيس إز كود بي جاست وي بي أو ماني كأس وي غو أور وي كاند كيب أسكين يو فور مور أند وي بي مور ماني إن ديبندس أون أنا قديش أقدر أشغل الموضوع عند أوذر سايب
Adnan ishgi: مرة يعتمد قد إيش أنا أقدر أدوف المشروع دا
Adnan ishgi: فإنت تعطيني أنا أقدر أعطيك.
Adnan ishgi: أقدر أطلب منك أقدر أقلبي قدي مزود ما يهمني ساعتها. تقولي وقت أنا أرتب معاك الوقت حسب ظروفك بس أنا أقدر أوسع المشروع بدل ما يكون أونلي كده متأخر لأن كل ما تأخرت كل المنظر حيكون مو مرة كويس بالنسبة لي صراحة.
Logix Inc: لا شوف أنا يمكن ما شفت
Logix Inc: أنا أرسلت لي في الجروب.
Adnan ishgi: أنا شفت أكثر من 1 والله صرت اتلخبط بيناتهم خلاص هو هذا صح؟ 25
Adnan ishgi: وأوغ.
Logix Inc: هذا على أساس إنه نبدأ. في كومبينز لانش على أساس خلاص خلصنا لكن قلنا حيصير شوية تأخير ممكن يعني الفيز هذه تتأخر شوي طبعا بناء عليها هذه تتأخر.
Adnan ishgi: هذا الله يسعدك هذا عشان أكون أجدول الفلوس كمان عشان ما أتأخر عليك
Adnan ishgi: جدولنا في الموضوع.
Logix Inc: تمام.
Adnan ishgi: كويس.
Logix Inc: تمام تمام.
Adnan ishgi: طيب أنا كده أظن كده هذا كدا خلص
Adnan ishgi: كده أظن.